hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i
recently did a top five 1080p
smartphones video and this device ended
at number one so it took crown for best
1080p smartphone and i've also been
tweeting about and talking about this
phone a lot and this is it this is time
to give it the full review treatment
this is the review of the htc one so the
one is a really interesting phone this
year for a couple of reasons number one
this is htc's main flagship so it seems
like it's their last hope and this is a
bit of a must-win phone for them and
number two it's competing directly
against samsung's flagship the galaxy s4
for sales and that's interesting because
htc actually took some serious risks
with this phone that you don't usually
really see in other phones and some of
them you already know what i'm talking
about already but we'll get to those in
a second but initially picking up this
phone and holding it is a pretty nice
experience which is pretty obvious it's
an all metal unibody aluminum back
design which kind of wraps around to the
front it's definitely not the thinnest
phone in the world and it's also
definitely not the lightest one in the
world either but it feels rather
sturdily built and that's always a good
thing in fact this is probably one of
the best things about this phone how
hefty it feels in the hand it feels
really good and how well everything fits
together with that back piece of metal
now some people have had small gaps
appear between the layers of the phone
and sometimes it's worse than others but
my phone my htc one feels pretty much
perfect so that's always good
the one thing about the outside hardware
of the htc one that i don't like is the
button placement mostly the power button
placement so the power button is up at
the top left hand corner which is a
little bit awkward but if you hold your
phone with your left hand you can get to
it and if you hold your phone with your
right hand you can get to it but i'm
just so used to tapping that right hand
side for power like i did on you know
samsung and motorola devices that it
kind of gets me it throws me off a
little bit and there are no buttons on
the left hand side of the phone there's
just this sim card tray and on the right
hand side is your volume rocker no power
button and speaking of all the placement
i guess we'll go over at the top is also
your three and a half millimeter
headphone jack and at the bottom is your
usb port and then out the front you have
some awesome awesome design features
going on here and and then some other
not so awesome ones but first of all you
have a 4.7 inch 1080p display coming in
at just shy of 470 pixels per inch it is
an extremely extremely nice display then
down at the bottom you have your htc
logo and just two buttons capacitive
buttons your home button and your back
button and you also have your boom sound
front-facing speakers
which we'll also talk about in a second
there's also a wide-angle front-facing
camera and the holes for the boom sound
speakers are micro drilled they're
really really high quality they look
pretty good and there's also a
notification light up top so overall the
front i like the design of this phone
it's kind of a two-tone design which is
you know a mixed bag some people don't
like it because it looks like an iphone
but honestly i think it has a pretty
unique appeal of its own on the back of
course you also have that band the
plastic bands are where the antenna
signals will go through that's where nfc
will happen that's where your radios and
bluetooth and everything will go through
basically you can't go through the metal
and then you also have your four ultra
pixel camera and your flash and you have
your att logo for this model and beats
audio
which is you know it's there actually no
let's talk about that let's talk about
that beats audio in fact i'll probably
do a separate video covering literally
everything about beats audio and phones
but you don't really need to know it now
all you need to know is that this
phone's front-facing speakers are
amazing they're incredible htc calls it
boom sound i call it awesome sound
whatever you want to call it it's a
wonder nobody's thought to do this in a
smartphone before and executed this well
like htc and not only are they
front-facing they're also stereo
speakers so if you're watching a movie
or playing a racing game or something
you can actually hear things move across
the screen from one speaker to the other
it's absolutely awesome and on top of
all of that on top of being front-facing
and stereo they're insanely great
quality drivers too more lows more mids
more highs more details just go ahead
and listen to this comparison with the
galaxy s4 and judge for yourself
there you go actions speak louder than
words here and these speakers combined
with probably the best smartphone
display on any phone i've ever used
period make it probably the best media
consumption experience that i've had in
my pocket and that is a huge reason to
buy this phone by itself now in terms of
media creation though this camera is a
pretty big deal
and the camera on the htc one is
actually not bad it's not bad at all now
i did a video explaining the whole ultra
pixel deal so i'll leave that link right
below the like button on this video if
you want to check that out but basically
the phone takes decent pictures and
regular light and outstanding pictures
and video in low light so if you care
about low light then this is probably
the best phone camera for you next to
the lumia 920 this problem here is that
because this is only a four megapixel
camera not 13 there's not as much detail
and when you're zooming in there's not
quite as much sharpness so htc decided
they're going to go ahead and add some
sharpening in software to make the
pictures appear as sharp as a 13
megapixel shot this works pretty well
for the most part until you can actually
tell like when something's supposed to
be blurry and out of focus and smooth in
the background the software tries to
sharpen it up and gives it this weird
look otherwise though the camera and the
optics are pretty great and the software
behind it has plenty of neat features
there's things like hdr shot and burst
shot and things called htc zoe which
basically gives you a few seconds of
video on like command basically really
quickly it's pretty great it's also
worth mentioning that the crop on this
phone is way wider there's a way wider
angle lens on the back and the front so
you can get way more in the shot which
is pretty nice and it's also worth
pointing out that there is tap to focus
and tap to meter so if you're metering
for exposure if you tap a dark area it's
going to blow up the photo and it'll be
really really light but if you tap a
white area it'll get really really dark
so you have to find the right area of
the photo to tap to get the right
exposure unless you trust the auto
exposure now inside the beast running
everything is a 1.7 gigahertz qualcomm
snapdragon 600 cpu excellent processor
never a doubt um this thing crutches
crushes benchmarks just like on the
galaxy s4 as we expected but i kind of
would have liked to see it matched up to
the galaxy s4 at 1.9 gigahertz i don't
know why it's just something about me
was wishing they didn't clock it down as
much but then again that's probably
going towards saving battery the fact is
this is a 2300 milliamp hour battery so
it's not quite as big but it lasts as
long as the galaxy s4 is 2600 milliamp
hour battery because of the slightly
lower cpu clock speed the slightly
slower ddr2 ram city of ddr3 the
slightly smaller display and a few other
things in software but it lasts me
basically a full day of heavy use from 7
am to about 8 pm no problem
but would you really want to use this
phone all day it's a pleasing experience
or not to be honest yes it definitely is
it's much better than previous htc phone
experiences the htc one is running the
newest version of sense ui called sense5
on top of android 4.1.2 jelly bean we'll
probably see some update to 4.2 pretty
soon and this phone is fast i mean
actually i'll take that back i think
quick is the better word it's a really
quick and responsive phone it's very
snappy that's another good word i love
everything about using it i've never
feel any sort of sutter or hiccup or
anything this thing flies through
multitasking performance is great i
never run out of ram there's two
gigabytes of ram and it's just an
awesome experience using this phone the
only delay i ever feel is when i
sometimes mispress that capacitive home
button or try to double tap and
accidentally get a single tap and it's
kind of wonky i end up doing this a lot
actually because in sense ui a double
tap of the home button brings you into
multitasking a single tap of the home
button brings you home and then a long
press of the home button brings you to
google now so there's a few actions you
kind of have to know with the home
button but after a while you get used to
it i've also accidentally pressed the
htc logo by default to try to wake up
the phone that's how long i was using
the galaxy note 2. uh even though the
keyboard though the keyboard is another
thing that is extra snappy i'm finding
that the autocorrect is also phenomenal
i actually think this is probably the
best keyboard on any smartphone i've
ever used so that's another huge win for
htc this keyboard is really really good
very fast just for regular typing and
it's also big enough for my pretty big
fingers and then there's also swiping so
you can use this keyboard uh over the
stock android keyword i've actually
found that i use it a lot more but
speaking of stock android this is a
double-edged sword there are a couple of
things that are weird really weird about
sense five for me number one is
blinkfeed i don't really use blinkfeed i
guess i can understand why people would
want it uh it's kind of customizable so
you can add your own sources and
everything so that's nice but
i would like to be able to completely
remove it from my home screen and not
accidentally see it every time i swipe
left number two is the app drawer and
the dock are one they are the same thing
they're part of the same thing it's
really weird so you know how you get
something out of the dock you should
just be able to drag it out and put it
somewhere else right wrong you just drag
a shortcut out of the app drawer too
because the dock is part of the app
drawer so of course it duplicates it and
replaces it with another one so that
means you can't drag things from the
dock to the home screen or you can but
you'll get another one so basically what
you have to do is go into the app drawer
and then drag it from the dock up into
the app drawer to get rid of it from the
dock it's it's just a weird process it
just takes away it should have just been
the same way stock android is to be
completely honest the dock and that
should be separate and then there's
another little quirk uh changing a
wallpaper you would think it would be
just as easy as a long press on the
wallpaper just like stock android right
wrong you'll just find widgets there
instead you have to change the wallpaper
by going and digging through the
settings and finding the personalized
setting and then picking a wallpaper
from in there so there's a whole bunch
of weird quirks like that about htc
sense 5 that htc could either fix or
just leave it there as a weird quirk
otherwise though using this phone has
been a blast the experience has been
really really nice and like i said it's
quick enough that it makes up for pretty
much all its shortcomings i love how
fast this phone is there's nothing i
would ever take away from the
performance and the speed of this phone
whatever it does whether it's weird or
not it does it fast and i love that
that's probably my favorite thing about
the htc one so that's basically it as
you can probably tell i am definitely a
fan of this phone in a lot of ways a lot
of people like to ask the question you
know what is your next daily driver and
to be honest i don't really have a daily
driver i do use different phones for
different things but honestly this is
probably a great choice for a phone for
the next two or three years if you sign
a contract with it i would have no
hesitation recommending this phone to
literally anyone that's how good this
htc one is so there you go thanks for
watching guys this has been a review and
if you enjoyed it definitely feel free
to give a thumbs up down below and if
you want to see more like it there's
also a subscribe button so you can do
that too either way yeah thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace
you